we now call it spy gate you're calling
it spy gate a lot of bad things have
happened I want them all to get together
they'll sit in the room hopefully
they'll be able to work it out among
themselves
we're not undercutting we're cleaning
everything up what I want is I want
total transparency any meeting between
the Justice Department and Capitol Hill
about such information should only be
attended by members of the gang of eight
I don't care who comes I'm not a control
of the invite list
well this meeting is going forward we
mentioned it earlier with John Roberts
the meeting tomorrow will include the
House Intelligence Committee chairman
Devin Nunez the House Oversight
Committee chairman trey Gowdy the FBI
director of the National Intelligence
director and the acting principal Deputy
Attorney General all of those will be at
this meeting at the DOJ about the
classified elements of this
investigation but we're being told that
there will likely be another meeting
with the gang of eight the bipartisan
leadership of Congress possibly after
the Memorial Day recess we'll start
there with all this investigation of the
investigation and bringing the panel
joining me here in Los Angeles Steve
Hillman former adviser to British Prime
Minister David Cameron and host of the
next revolution here on fox news and
lesley marshall syndicated talk radio
host and in Washington Marr lives in
national political correspondent of
National Public Radio and Matthew cotton
Annie editor-in-chief of the Washington
free beacon Steve let me start with you
your thoughts on how this is all coming
out and the significance of well Brett
it wasn't that long ago that the left
and parts of the establishment media I'm
thinking in particular the New York
Times were deeply suspicious of what we
now describe is the deep state when we
had James clapper going to Congress and
lying about surveilling the American
people there's this suspicion of the
security services and the intelligence
agencies and now now that they seem to
be against Trump we're supposed to
believe that they're purer than pure
everything that they say is gospel and
there's no grounds for any suspicion I
think there's no question that there are
sufficient reasons to think that the
establishment in the government
bureaucracy for
that the prospect of a trump presidency
was unthinkable unacceptable and took
steps to try and stop it there's enough
suspicion there to think that we really
do need a thorough investigation that's
equivalent to the investigation in
Russia meddling which is really
important to look at the potential of
deep state meddling mara I don't know
are you calling it spy gate who's
calling it spy game very happy it sounds
that he's branded something new he is a
Superbrand ER and he's come up with spy
gate and as he said today you're calling
it spy gate I'm calling it spy gate
everyone's talking about this he said it
could be the biggest scandal in American
history what he's talking about
according to his tweets is that there
was someone a spy as he calls it
embedded in his campaign for political
purposes to spy on the campaign so far
there's no evidence of that we don't
know if he's talking about an FBI
informant who met with certain members
of the campaign reached out to them to
find out what contacts they had with
Russians but if the president wanted to
he can declassify any piece of
information he wants he could have asked
any of his intelligence officials over
the last couple of weeks or months to
say hey tell me what you know was there
a spy embedded in my campaign I don't
think he wants to know I think he wants
to keep this story going this is a good
narrative for him and it helps him
undermine the credibility of the
investigations into him and his campaign
yeah I want to talk about another
development Lesley and that is the the
Jared Kushner getting security clearance
today finally after a long period of
time a national security law attorney
former FBI agent told us quote this is a
very significant development the bureau
would have had very senior people on
this and the matter would have been
reviewed and approved at the most senior
levels given all the circumstances this
decision would be highly vetted and
considered they wouldn't be deeming him
eligible for access to classified
materials no matter what level of the
clearance if there were any outstanding
counterintelligence concerns whatsoever
again a very significant development one
person's assessment of this your
thoughts well I think this I don't think
that Jared Kushner is the problem I
think the president and his rhetoric of
the problem and I think that's caused a
problem not only for
some in law but the tensions that we
have seen with the rhetoric toward the
FBI and other law enforcement agencies
that are supposed to be working for our
country and for the Constitution and
have their loyalty there when we go back
to Mara's point you know when you call
the spy gate and and I know I'm not
calling a spy gate okay I just want to
go on the record there let's let's just
speak about spy gate if we will the role
of the FBI and anybody even if they've
worked for a Republican president if it
is this gentleman all the way back to
Ronald Reagan is to do exactly this is
to say hey wait a minute there have been
some conversations between Russia and
those in the United States Paul Manafort
has been indicted Paul Manafort is one
of the people that was spoken to and
Tamara's point the president certainly
has the power to find out if there was a
spy embedded if there truly was Spygate
this is deflection why deflect from the
Muller Special Counsel investigation if
there's nothing to hide it no they're
both things are going forward and well
we always say we don't know what we
don't know but we're covering both sides
the reason I bring up the Jared Kushner
thing is how that was covered early on
in this process suggested that because
of all his foreign contacts and and all
of this the the questions that were
raised about Jared Kushner that there
was no way he was going to get security
clearance and somehow he could be
charged or indicted that was the
coverage and the and the speculation now
he's cleared right in as one a former
official told catherine herridge in her
report brett that would imply that the
those counterintelligence concerns no
longer exist if he has been granted this
security coverage i like to quote donald
rumsfeld there are so many known
unknowns about now the investigation
into Russian interference and also the
investigation of the investigation which
is really let's remember coming from
Congress as much as Donald Trump is
publicizing it and in fact aiding it
there are a lot of concerns from the
House Intelligence Committee about how
did this start and I think that's one of
the great unknown known unknowns rather
is when did this investigation open what
was in the original
order that Deputy Attorney General
Rosenstein gave to to Robert Muller we
still don't know the full details of
that they also don't know about this
other British or semi British professor
Masood who would met with George
papadopolis he hasn't been seen in
public in months so the the known
unknowns continued to mount where where
do you think this goes and how fast do
you think it comes to resolution I
really don't know we know what Rudy
Giuliani says about it that he'll be
done by September Muller will be done by
September the problem with covering this
is that every little twist and turn we
don't know the big picture we Bob Muller
isn't talking to his credit so we're
covering this through a straw and
everything seems like the biggest deal I
just would say the bottom line to me for
today for Jared Kushner this was a good
day for Jared Kushner and it was a good
week for Jared Kushner because he
started working on a substance of
substantive policy that has bipartisan
support in Congress and that's prison
reform
that's exactly right we'll be following
that as it makes its way to sorry passed
the house and now had to do the Senate